zack snyder's justice league is an
ambitious
four-hour epic packed with tons of
previously unseen footage
as well as contradictions and
unexplained moments here are those
confusing moments explained
of all the minor continuity
discrepancies between the dc eu movies
one of the most
noticeable is the case of aquaman's eye
color
if you've missed out on the whedon cut
of justice league back in 2017
then you may be used to the brown
yellows closer to jason momoa's natural
eye color and james wants aquaman
in the 2017 justice league aquaman can
be seen with striking baby blues
this coloring was brought back again in
the snyder cut leaving some viewers
reasonably confused as it turns out this
is a choice both directors are very
aware of and
cite as an artistic difference but
according to momoa it was a decision
motivated by something the actor himself
said in an interview with the huffington
post promoting aquaman back in 2018
momoa revealed about the change
it was my idea i brought to zack i
thought it would be rad to have a
different eye color something that's
completely atlantean
that was like his mark i felt like it
was just something that would be a
little
otherworldly so zack really liked it as
for
why director james wan went in a
different direction momoa said
i feel like juan wanted to have a warmer
thing in this movie
i feel like my justification for the
change is that he kind of went
home he's more rooted and he's calm when
he's around his family
another inconsistency between aquaman
batman vs superman dawn of justice and
zack snyder's justice league has no real
bearing on their overall plots but
is a detail that can be irksome to
anyone following the dcu releases
thus far it's time to talk about the
trident in zack snyder's justice league
queen atlanta's trident is presented to
aquaman by volkow
vulco encourages aquaman to take the
trident and claim his birthright to the
throne of atlantis
he declines setting up the 2018 aquaman
arc
in the theatrical version of the film
this was replaced by a scene between
meera and aquaman after steppenwolf
steals the mother box hidden in atlantis
it's implied that mira gives aquaman the
trident that he uses to fight in the
rest of the film
in both cuts of the film he uses the
trident during battle with parrot demons
but
the moment where aquaman seems to ask
for the trident doesn't exist in the
snyder cut
i'm gonna need something from you
however that still doesn't explain the
footage first shown in snyder's previous
movie batman vs superman which
shows aquaman with a trident that looks
pretty much exactly like the weapon he
wields in justice league
does aquaman just have an extra trident
that looks
just like his mother's this is another
perplexing moment that is a result of
creative changes made following the
lackluster theatrical release of justice
league the way snyder envisioned
underwater communications between
atlanteans works just fine for his movie
but
james wan made some changes to fit his
vision for aquaman
in both versions of justice league all
underwater conversations between
atlanteans happen in air bubbles they
create
in james wan's aquaman the atlanteans no
longer require these bubbles to speak to
each other underwater
why did this happen whenever you noticed
something like that
a wizard did it well not really
juan said in an entertainment weekly
interview people are overthinking it
they're just gonna talk honestly it's
hard to imagine him having any other
stance snyder's stylish portrayal of
atlantean communication
would have quickly become annoying in a
movie that takes place primarily
in atlantis to many who grew up with the
justice league comics and cartoons
green lantern is a core member of the
league sadly
the colossal bomb that was 2011's green
lantern movie with ryan reynolds
ensured that dc won't be touching hal
jordan for a
good while but it seems like snyder has
put the wheels in motion to one day
bring green lantern back into the fold
the climax of the second part of zack
snyder's justice league is a flashback
of
epic proportions it depicts the first
age of heroes and the final battle
between darkseid and the humans
atlanteans and amazons
the one lantern visible jalen gur was in
the original cut but in the snyder cut
he explicitly dies by darkseid's hand
the scene also highlights how the ring
escaped and continued the hero's line
which presumably
would have been followed up on in a
future justice league sequel
yellen gore wasn't the only lantern that
made an appearance in the snyder cut
kilowog set up to be one of the main
characters in hbo max's green lantern
core series
appears dead in cyborg's vision of the
desolate future timeline
aka the nightmare one of the most
surprising and unusual changes made to
the snyder cut
comes from a character who isn't in the
movie for a terribly long amount of
screen time
still it's enough to notice how snyder
has made meera change her accent
or at least it seems that way the truth
is
probably much simpler in aquaman and
2017's justice league
heard voiced the atlantean queen with an
accent that sounded more or less like
her regular speaking voice my parents
fought in the wars
she took me what a saint you dare speak
of queen atlanta that way
zack snyder's justice league has heard
putting on a british accent
my parents died in the water
she took me what a saint
you dare speak of queen atlanta that way
it's likely that the original scenes
with mirror for the movie were already
completely finished and were simply
added back for the snyder cut
this means that the mirror scenes in
2017's justice league are almost
certainly reshoots this choice is minor
and in keeping with snyder's objective
to completely preserve his original
vision for the film if you are at all
confused about the scene with lois lane
and a green
space alien impersonating martha kent
don't worry
sir weak later revealing himself to
bruce wayne and to the dc universe at
large
martian manhunter aka jon jones makes
his live-action debut in zack snyder's
justice league in a mysterious scene
at the end of a long conversation
between lois and martha about clark
martha exits and unbeknownst to lois
shapeshifts first into martian manhunter
and then into secretary of defense
calvin swanwick
in the scene martha advises lois that
she still needs to be part of society
which motivates her to get out
placing her in the right place at the
right time when superman is brought back
to life
this moment is pivotal and the knowledge
that martian manhunter was orchestrating
events in the movie the whole time
is mind-blowing martian manhunter was
one of the original justice league
members
and his appearance of the snyder verse
brings the league's new total
up to that oh so important number seven
now that we know what snyder planned for
two justice league sequels
we know he was going to expand the group
and bring in green lantern and other dc
legends but now the future of martian
manhunter in the dc eu
remains uncertain a very
important part of the snyder verse is
the nightmare
it's never really explained in either
batman vs superman dawn of justice or
zack snyder's justice league nor is it
referred to by name
still understanding it is vital to
understanding the greater meaning behind
many of the new additions to the snyder
cut the nightmare
is introduced in batman vs superman when
bruce dreams of being in a sandy
washed out desert after being ambushed
by a group of men
batman sees parademons coming in the
distance and is overtaken
this vision concludes with the reveal of
an evil superman
and bruce being awoken to a flash from
the future telling him
lois is the key it's a reference to what
happens in
justice league but also is a clue to her
importance in the now
shuttered sequels snyder was planning
the nightmare itself makes a return in
the snyder cut where it becomes clear
that darkseid is the cause of the
apocalyptic future
it's never explicitly stated but snyder
has explained that this is a vision of
the future that must be
stopped in the snyder cut we see
superman holding the burned body of lois
in the batcave
which is the turning point that bruce
must never let happen
there is a lot to love about zack
snyder's justice league but admittedly
it doesn't explain some of its biggest
concepts
such as what exactly is the anti-life
equation and
why does darkseid want it so badly
originally created for dc's fourth world
arc in 1970 the anti-life equation is a
secret way of controlling all sentient
beings
darkseid believes part of the equation
exists in the subconscious of humanity
which is why steppenwolf interrogates
people using those creepy spider bugs
thematically a common interpretation is
that the equation is a mathematical
proof of the futility of living
and a way to dominate humanity through
spreading hopelessness
what it actually is and whether or not
it has a physical form in the snyder
verse
is one of the biggest mysteries for the
future of the dc eu
it's not explained at all in the movie
but superman's
pitch black suit has great historical
significance that references one of
snyder's key inspirations
for his justice league the black suit in
zack snyder's justice league is a
reference to 1993's
the reign of superman comic arc the
follow-up to previous years
the death of superman which saw superman
die while fighting doomsday
when he comes back to life in rain he's
wearing the black suit in an iconic
moment of dc
comics history since then it has always
been associated with the death
and return of superman in the lore the
suit was designed to help the weakened
superman absorb more solar energy
so he can be stronger after coming back
to life while this may be obvious to
older dc comics fans it's not left
unexplained for no reason
there was actually a deleted scene that
was shot during snyder's original
production
that showed a newly resurrected superman
choosing to don
either a suit of kryptonian armor or the
iconic black
suit joe manganiello joined the dc
universe's deathstroke in a mid-credits
scene in the theatrical cut of justice
league back in 2017.
the yacht scene that served as his
introduction is
in the snyder cut but in an altered form
however the restored version of the
scene is more confusing than anything
else
in the theatrical justice league
deathstroke's introduction was a teaser
for a legion of doom movie where luther
gathers a band of villains to face off
against
the justice league shouldn't we have a
league of our own
[Music]
in the version of the scene that made it
into the snyder cut luther tells
deathstroke batman's true identity which
is a significant difference at the time
snyder's intention was to make a
stand-alone ben
affleck batman film following justice
league with manganello's deathstroke
serving as the main villain
affleck dropped out and the batman
eventually turned into the robert
pattinson lead matt reeves directed
project currently in production
now both versions of justice league have
scenes teasing movies
that will never see the light of day the
nightmare scene in the epilogue
is the most dire of all parademons roam
the land while batman and the rest of
the league are at the end of their rope
aquaman is dead replaced by mira
deathstroke is working with the league
and flash is wearing his future costume
from batman vs superman flashback
jared leto's joker makes his return to
mock the dark knight
one last time he and batman make
important references to the deaths of
robin
harley quinn and lois lane before joker
offers bruce a truce the sequence ends
with the league
preparing for what might just be one
last battle at the end of the world with
superman
the scene is loaded with implications
about what might have happened in the
future of the snyder verse
it confirms the death of robin at the
hands of the joker and that bruce
letting lois die in a tragic blast is
the turning point of the conflict
according to snyder
this tragedy allows superman to succumb
to the anti-life equation and therefore
fall completely under darkseid's control
time travel and multiverses were going
to play a major role in justice league
two and three but now this single scene
is the most we'll see of zack snyder's
dark
justice league trilogy check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite new movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]